So their answer is both of the last two. Both of
these will need to go through the loop here, the number of
elements in index times. In the case where it's a word that's
not in a index, the test will always be false, and will
get to the end of the loop and return none. In
the case where the last word is added, we'll still go through
the loop, the number of elements times, but the very last time
we'll find a match, and return that element. One of the assumptions
in all of this analysis is that the time it
takes to go through the loop doesn't depend on the actual
keyword that's passed in. And that's assuming that this equal
comparison takes the same amount of time depending on what the
entry and the keyword is. That it doesn't matter what
the keyword is the time to do this comparison is the
same. And it turns out that for strings and Python that's
the case. That we can do these string comparisons very quickly,
because strings are immutable. That means that we don't need to look
at all the characters in the string to compare two strings. That
double equal for strings can be done in such a way that
it doesn't need to look at the whole string. It knows that the
strings were created as different strings.
That means they're different strings. Or
if they were created as the same string, they're the same string. So
that's the reason why we say that all of the other operations
in the loop have constant time. That they don't depend on the size
of inputs at all. These are all very fast operations. What
matters in terms of understanding the time is the number of times
we go through that index. If you take the follow on course,
which I hope you will, we'll understand how to analyze algorithms in
a more formal way. For now our goal is to develop
an intuition, and for that intuition the important thing to understand is
the running time depends on the number of times we go through
this loop. Everything that we do inside the loop is constant time.
It's not affected by the size of the elements.